веду промову, що свого сина Петра вперше
по бачку диньку лисюк засідки на 11
рокки
ви рук за статейку військо валентин він
прямо все частіше будемо товари бувають при
темряві у російського оборонного
промислову кампусу нині even у
лефортово чекаючи на від іван і бочки
раз повідають син сором інста цекало вся
ризикову техніку та зокрема авіацію та
показувати йог мишкою проте не вірять що
valentine банан і до жити з віч і не з
його ви бували і ось якщо за за три
манія вивезення ви близько туман і
розтирав і був і
обличчя блоки з ми ж добу праворуч і воланд
іншого і всього опікуються активісти праворуч
запасний організації років травень піпл гоу
марія тумак лиша бралася а потім
пояснивши кремля
ви на них від кіно мало щуки кицьку чудових
праворуч будуть росстат і застане їх
домоглися і закривання кримських татар
якупова на муки острові прогноз
правозахисниці нафтовий загинув
в процесі введення вуса більше вона
гейна викликало не менше, але я боюся а що
воно і в обмін на українських громадян
попросіть кисть там сухо мандрівникові рада
рада криму
обидва ще сінні acquisto керати її і тут
А відповідаю на Україну будемо на
поступово проси і пара горне по витівках
за допомогою правозахисний закликав
таїться та обидва з е у антора до Європи
нині у всі свої сус або з приму вав і
його викинуть з російських змінити купа
порожніх 4 українців розумних навчалася на
проблеми зі здоров'ям
стане славка life 1 злих і осман його
трохи почистив парчі чеченський виньї
тамара на поганого якщо вона не бачила
сином а я ж повтору рок ой а поїхати в
грізний домагається суд хороший на травень
було засідання суду гвинтам 3 в страшно
ось шо я хочу до дому будь то панель
їхати туди думаючи ні в чому не винні
ось це психічної атаки і народила б
ну він же з України каже наші ватки
звивина neues їх 20 5 з них кремля
спарюватися з нею в роті у віті якесь
вже своїх громадян бореться догматичним
розуму це вдома російський консул
регулярного криму я але ти протестуєш у
нові пропан цю практику системних
порушений для громадян України